and what I want to do is give you a
little bit of history on the automobile
and then tell you where I think it's
headed and how it ties to the future of
energy first of all a few numbers of the
global automobile industry is massive in
scale 850 million cars and trucks about
70 million new ones a year being built
and there's growth happening in the
emerging markets especially places like
China today China is the largest
automotive market in the world and
enormous inertia because of the scale
but also because of this codependence
between the roads and the energy and how
we manage traffic what's happened here
is there's a lot of freedom that people
realize from owning their own car they
can go where they want when they want
traveling with the people that they want
to travel with carrying what they would
like to travel but the challenge is that
the automobile depends almost
exclusively on oil for energy emit co2
which is contributing to climate change
1.2 million people a year worldwide die
on roadways
that's epidemic in scale no matter how
you cut it and then finally the
congestion results in severe traffic
delays so the history is that a hundred
and twenty-five years ago a Karl Benz
patented the first gasoline-powered
automobile he probably didn't realize
that the same makeup of his design which
was a mechanical Drive with the
combustion engine using oil as the basis
for energy controlled mechanically and
hydraulically by people on the
standalone basis that's still a hundred
25 years later that would be the
fundamental design makeup of this
technology there are not too many
industries in the world where you would
look at their product and say that
hasn't changed for over a century
this is likely unsustainable I think for
all of the reasons that you are you're
confronting in your company as well but
I want to give you a little quiz first
you're asked to do a little bit of
homework so some of you might get this
right but this will give you some
encouragement on the sustainability
concern how much of the energy in a
gallon of gasoline is used to move the
driver of a car
it's 1% and I say how could that be one
gallon the gasoline when you combust it
75% of the BTUs are lost as heat and
friction so only 25% moved the wheels
and a typical car weighs 3,000 pounds
and a typical person weighs 150 pounds
and when you do the arithmetic only 1%
of those BTUs are moving the person in
the car I would argue that we have a
systems design opportunity not an energy
a challenge and automobile
transportation it's that system design
that I want to help you understand a bit
more a lot of different things are
driving change I know these are small
words but energy politics energy
security oil and price of gas price
volatility climate change regulations
globalization technology energy
economics all of those things are just
pointing at the need for transformation
I'm not talking about evolution because
the scale of this industry is so large
and it has been evolving for 125 years
we need to transform and I think the
single most important thing to pay
attention to in this transformation is
the consumer fact the market in my mind
is the only mechanism that will allow
you to realize change on the scale
that's required and consumers are right
at the heart of the market and in
transportation you have people who need
to drive in stop-and-go traffic and
continuous driving on highways some
carry light loads and some carry heavy
loads and what ties all this together is
the sharing of the roadway system in the
parking system so until we can find
solutions that really excite consumers
and those solutions also also can be
sold at a price that exceeds the cost of
supplying it so we can make some money
doing it till we can get to that magic
point it's going to be tough to get to
large-scale solutions now what's
exciting about this is that there is an
design DNA that that has emerged for the
automobile finally after 125 years
technology has converged for us to think
about electrical drive rather than
mechanical I would contend that's the
biggest differentiator don't get hung up
on batteries or anything like that it's
how do you actually turn the wheel and
there's a big difference between
electric Drive and mechanical drive in
terms of simplicity and how you can
excite the customers electric motors
diverse sources of energy so not just
oil but a wide range electronic and
digital controls and believe it or not
we're talking about cars that can drive
themselves or driverless cars that are
connected virtually communicating with
each other on a network so they can
avoid each other in crashes and we can
manage their flow much more
intelligently so we've entered into a
very exciting period in terms of what
the future might hold
now I entered one of those periods just
after I was married my wife and I went
on a honeymoon there's a wonderful place
in the western United States called the
Grand Canyon and you get to ride these
burros down into the canyon these
animals get down to the river my wife
was in front of me and her burro tripped
and she said that's one then it stumbled
a little bit more and she said that's
two and then finally a really really
stumble a lot and she almost fell off
and she said that's three and she got
off her animal and pushed it off the
cliff and I said geez honey I realize he
tripped but aren't you overreacting and
she said that's one so the whole point
of this is you need to understand the
questions to understand the future and
this is a very exciting future one that
promises truly transformational change
so I'm going to give you a little bit
more background on what that entails
first electric vehicles are here this is
not something that needs to be invented
any longer
you may have read about the mists on
leaf but we also have the Chevrolet Volt
is called the Emperor and
Europe the Fisker Karma Henrik Fisker
was a designer from BMW that went out on
his own and his design just an
extraordinary car that drives
electrically both of these have a
battery and an engine so the charge and
the battery is depleted the engine acts
as a generator to create more
electricity to drive the car these are
pure plug-in electric vehicles from Ford
to Tesla to Nissan and many others so
the auto industry is starting to to
reach this transformational point I want
to emphasize there's a whole nother type
of electric vehicle but it is an
electric vehicle with a different kind
of battery what you might call a
hydrogen battery and those are fuel cell
electric vehicles if any of you followed
the Frankfurt Auto Show recently you
would have seen a diner of concept
called the F 125 they're actually
celebrating the 125 year history of karl
benz inventing the car the f 125 is a
fuel cell electric vehicle and it's an
extraordinarily premium vehicle the good
news is at Daimler Honda Hyundai Toyota
and General Motors are all developing
commercial fuel cell vehicles that will
be in the market in 2014 to 2015 Germany
actually is leading the way with a plan
that put 1,000 hydrogen stations in
place in line with the deployment of the
supply of vehicles because you don't
want a station without cars neither want
to occurs without stations and Germany
has created a mechanism of working
between the government and the auto
companies and the energy suppliers to
deploy a plan for a thousand stations so
this is becoming very exciting what I
want to emphasize those not to get too
confused with all these different types
of electric cars because at the end of
the day is it's a lot simpler than what
you might think over here we have
mechanical power you take a fuel like
gasoline you burn it in an engine that
creates power that's transferred
mechanically to the wheels we've been
doing that a long time there's a lot of
parts in that
the moving parts in the engine the
moving parts in the transmission all the
way back to the axles of the front axles
over on this side we have pure electric
drive you store energy with a battery or
your store energy is hydrogen with a
fuel cell and that electricity is to
simply take it to electric motors that
drive the wheels in between you have
mechanical drive with electrical assist
that's called the hybrid and you have
electrical drive with mechanical assist
that's called an extended-range electric
vehicle this is a Nissan Leaf this is
the Chevrolet Volt this is the Toyota
Prius and these are all the cars and
trucks were used to experiencing what's
important is that the battery is very
much at the heart of this opportunity
but it still is in its infancy now you
might say how could that be no Thomas
Edison was working on batteries in the
late 1800s and there were a lot of
electric cars in that time frame well
this is tough tough stuff to do let acid
batteries to nickel metal hydride
batteries - not lithium-ion batteries
and a battery is asked to do a very
ambitious set of tasks it has to be
affordable durable safe small enough to
put on the car it has to recharge fast
and it has to be integrated with the
infrastructure lithium-ion batteries are
promising but their generation one
batteries right now and any of us who
have experience developing technology
realize we need to go from generation 1
to generation 2 and typically in the
auto industry to generation 3 before
they get to a cost and value
a proposition to go to high volume so
what you have to keep in mind as you pay
attention to these battery electric
vehicles is that there are three
commercial learning cycles to get to
that magic moment when value exceeds
price and price exceeds cost I believe
we can get there
but I think it's going to take us a good
10 to 12 more years of experience with
these electric vehicles for that to
happen we're also going to have to make
significant investment in the
infrastructure and meet a wide range of
consumer requirements many of which
won't be able to be met by pure plug-in
electric vehicle now I haven't studied
Europe carefully but I've studied this
infrastructure issue in the United
States and that the problem is in this
last mile to the house or to the
charging location we have a 120 volt
system and these cars that I described
after charge overnight so a lot of
people want to get to a 240 volt system
so that cars can charge in two to three
hours but the substations and most of
the local areas just can't handle a lot
of the cars doing that at the same time
so then people said we want to manage
that with a smart grid and then they get
ideas at geez if we have all these
batteries out there we can bring
electricity from the batteries back into
the grid all of these are exciting ideas
and it will play out I think but over a
longer time frame than a lot of the
politicians and other people are hyping
right now this is this again it is very
significant investment in the United
States I apologize for not having
European numbers only 30 percent of the
cars are actually parked in a garage
overnight 70 percent are parked on the
street or in parking structures so even
if we could get the fast-charging sorted
out we'll need a lot more infrastructure
than just what's in people's homes
that's why hydrogen fuel cell technology
is so important and it's not one or the
other I happen to
one of my biggest lessons as an
executive is to focus on the word and
not the word or it's electric vehicles
with batteries and electric vehicles
with fuel cells because they serve
different customers a fuel cell is just
simply a battery that provides
electricity as long as you have hydrogen
available so you store hydrogen onboard
the vehicle which happens to be the most
plentiful element in the universe
unfortunately it's bonded to something
all the time even carbon in a fossil
fuel like natural gas was bonded to
oxygen and water and it takes energy to
break those bonds and make that hydrogen
available but when we do that we can
store it on board the vehicle and we can
come up with a vehicle that's more than
twice as efficient as a combustion
engine it has no more precious metal in
it than the catalytic converters that
clean up the emissions from an engine
you can get a range and durability and
performance comparable to today's cars
with 60% fewer parts at 90 percent fewer
moving parts and you can handle all
kinds of environments so what am i
telling you with a hydrogen fuel cell
vehicle you can pull into a station like
you do today refuel and five to eight
minutes and go three to 400 miles and
drive purely electrically and emit just
water vapor so the big challenge then is
is this affordable and how do you get
the hydrogen to that station the answer
to the affordability question is in my
mind yes not immediately but just like
with batteries through three commercial
learning cycles there's nothing in that
pile of molecules that make up this fuel
cell engine to suggest it should cost
more than an internal combustion engine
it's just the lack of a supply base and
the competitive price dynamics
come with them in terms of hydrogen it
can come from so many different sources
a lot of people will get focused well is
this an efficient thing to do with
hydrogen to take electricity for example
and electrolyze water and split hydrogen
and oxygen apart
oh that's about 70% efficient wouldn't
we be better off to just put that
electricity in a battery and drive an
electric car well there are some
scenarios here like when the wind blows
that's not an efficiency question that's
a capital utilization question the winds
gonna blow hard some days independent of
the efficiency so the opportunity with
hydrogen is to find innovative ways to
create it either from when or biomass or
very importantly from natural gas and
supply it to customers um where they
need it the good thing about the battery
electric vehicle and the fuel cell
electric vehicles they share a lot of
parts again it's an we need better
motors better power electronics and
controls better storage capabilities
cooling systems connectors and materials
so by working on both of them together
we're going to move all of that forward
together with the fuel cell vehicle
serving people who have more of a family
car need driving greater distances and
the battery electric perhaps being
ideally suited for city driving and
that's how we need to think about that
let me give you another quiz now this
one's a little more tricky how far can
you drive on the amount of gasoline you
can pump in one hour 7,000 miles so if
you grab a gasoline hose and you stand
there in your pump and pump and pump for
an hour and you take all that gasoline
and use it you can dry 7,000 miles the
amount of hydrogen that you can pump in
one hour so you grab your hydrogen hose
700 bar you pump a pump for an hour
5,000 miles not too bad the amount of
electricity you can store in a battery
in one hour so you plug your car in for
an hour and recharge the battery
on 120-volt five miles and on 240-volt
20 miles now I'm not saying this to say
the battery isn't going to went out on
the minds of consumers I really believe
and I'm going to give you an example
where I think batteries fit but this is
a practical reality of the consumers the
850 million people today in the world
that own a car are used to an experience
of going to a refueling station spending
five to ten minutes pumping gasoline or
diesel fuel and having to do that once a
week and getting a 300 or 400 mile range
as a result so this is simply a
different experience one that requires a
different infrastructure so if in your
company are wondering is this gonna
really change the world these batteries
and all this plug ins stuff it's going
to impact the world
it has promise but it's not going to
happen at a speed that's so
transformational about your company
couldn't respond to it in an intelligent
way the good news is about this concern
of oil the fact that 90% of the energy
and transportation comes from oil is
that we have a lot of different ways to
make energy that can be used on an
automobile you can take fossil fuels
like oil natural gas and you can create
gasoline and diesel fuels and you can
compress the natural gas and burn it in
the combustion engine with mechanical
Drive you can also take those fossil
fuels and biomass and nuclear wind solar
and geothermal and make liquid biofuels
electricity and hydrogen and use those
either for combusting the mechanical
drive or for electrical drive so what
I'm trying to do again is make this
simple for you there's mechanical
driving there's electrical drive
there's fossil fuels and on fossil fuels
and there's pathways that take these
primary or raw energy sources and turn
them into a variety of energy carriers
that can support these different Drive
systems so as I mentioned only 1% of the
BTUs and a gallon the gasoline are used
the person shame on us as engineers if
we can't figure out a way given all of
this opportunity to solve these problems
now how many of you are engineers by
background ok I was once told that the
definition of an engineer is someone who
likes to work with numbers but doesn't
have the personality to be an accountant
no I don't think that's true but I think
engineers are going to be key to solving
this problem ok what why am I so
optimistic I fully recognize there's a
lot of controversy around natural gas
that's obtained from hydraulic
fracturing of shale and different
countries are weighing in on that in
different ways I'm employed by the earth
Institute here at Columbia so they
immediately focus on the environmental
risks of obtaining the natural gas
whether that's a risk of surface water
pollution whether that's a risk of
contaminating the water table or the
leakage of methane into the atmosphere
or the actual fracturing causing
something to happen down the road that
we didn't anticipate as an engineer I
believe those are risks to be managed
and can be managed through proper
learning the fact is in the United
States our reserves of natural gas have
increased depending on who you talk to
50 to 100 years because of the
availability of natural gas from shale
and that natural gas looks like it wants
to cause somewhere between three and
five dollars per million BTUs very
inexpensive natural gas that's very
plentiful the good news in
transportation is that you can compress
it and burn it you can plug it in to a
battery by making electricity from it at
a combined heat and power efficient
power plant or you can strip the
hydrogen off the carbon and make the
hydrogen stored in a fuel cell vehicle
and dry the fuel cell another test if
you had a liter of natural gas
you could do one of these three things
which one would take you the farthest
converting it to hydrogen for fuel cells
converting it to electricity for plug-in
electric or compressing it and burning
it in the combustion engine it's this
last one you can go farther on that
natural gas by reforming it into
hydrogen second a close second i would
say is electricity in a very distant
third is to compress it and burn it so
I'm personally troubled by people who
are saying
hooray we have all this natural gas
let's compress it and burn it and get
off of oil because I think we can use it
two to two-and-a-half times as
efficiently if we followed these
electrically driven pathways this is a
big issue this is not an issue that
plays out over a couple years it's going
to play out over several decades so we
need to make a wise decision here
interestingly biomass again a lot of
different perspectives around the world
on whether we should use biomass here
I'm talking mostly about non-food based
biomass forestry waste municipal waste
sewage waste the waste from the corn not
the kernel but the corn stalk all of
that different nations have different
amounts of biomass interestingly you can
turn that into ethanol
that's what Brazil does you can burn it
at a power plant and make electricity
and a lot of power companies are trying
to do that because they have renewable
fuel standards and a good way to do that
is you per biomass or you can reform it
and turn it into hydrogen now you better
get this next question right if you have
a ton of biomass and you can use it
three ways which one will you go the
farthest on
this one hydrogen a few ourselves a
close second as electricity in a distant
third is ethanol now wind and solar also
play because you can make electricity
for plugins and you can also make
hydrogen I would contend again this is
more of a capital utilization question
than it is an efficiency question and
the big challenge is storing surplus
electricity that comes from wind and
what is going on in Germany and some
other places is to store that as
hydrogen you can store a lot more
hydrogen compressed in a salt cavern in
electricity then you can't pumping water
up on a mountain or compressing air or
actually even using batteries so the
good news is a lot of different ways to
do this the challenge is not one of
invention and know-how excuse me yes I
think safety is the number one priority
the good news is engineers know how to
work with hydrogen I would argue that
liquid hydrocarbons are also very
dangerous molecules and when you watch
movies in the United States you can't
see one without a car crash in the car
it's floating from the gasoline hydrogen
is different it's not more dangerous or
less dangerous you just have to engineer
your storage systems and your fuel
systems differently our engineering
Center when I was at General Motors is
based in Mainz Germany and we use
European standards for these 700 bar
tanks that we store hydrogen in and it
requires expanding and contracting and
expanding the contracting many many
cycles because that's what happens when
you refuel we shoot bullets at it we
drop it from powers we even do crashes
with it and fortunately to date the
system
we've engineered our doing very very
well the risky scenario with hydrogen is
if you have it contained in an ignites
the biggest challenge with hydrogen is
keeping it contained and so in some ways
it has some advantages from safety
I worry actually more about the
mechanical energy storing hydrogen at
700 bar on the vehicle then I do
igniting the hydrogen and at burning but
I think I think we just have to work
with that well and just evolve new
standards and manage that appropriately
I think it's a risk to be managed but a
very very important question so in terms
of this energy diversity challenge again
1% of the BTUs and gasoline move the
person a lot of different sources of
energy and two different types of
propulsion systems we really chicken an
egg challenge so to say the vehicles
depend on the energy supply and the
energy producers need vehicles to make
money so it's an economic challenge the
capital for the infrastructure and to
get to a competitive cost now one of the
companies I advise here in the United
States is headquartered here in
Manhattan is Hess corporation Hess
explores for oil and natural gas and
produces oil and natural gas and sells
it through retail stations along the
east coast they also own a company
called move era fuel cells and new Vera
has technology to reform natural gas at
the scale of a gasoline station you need
about 500 kilograms to 1500 kilograms a
day so rather than thinking about a
refinery which makes a lot of hydrogen
with a technology called steam methane
reforming think about it at the scale of
an everyday station and they've
rethought the reformer around that
opportunity the good news is with
natural gas at $6 price the equivalent
cost of gasoline that it would compete
with is in the dollar 50 to $2 50 range
so if we do have plentiful natural
we can pipe it as natural gas to the
station so we solve how do you
distribute hydrogen you distribute it as
natural gas then you strip the hydrogen
off the carbon at the station is that
efficient and cost competitive yes it is
does that create co2 yes but half as
much per mile as burning the natural gas
so a lot of exciting opportunities and I
want to totally shift over to a
different subject and this is actually
the more transformational technology
that I'll talk about today now you're an
energy business and certainly different
types of propulsion and different types
of energy will be important in
transportation but I think hopefully
I'll convince you even more importantly
or what we call connected vehicles and
autonomous vehicles a connected vehicle
is a vehicle that communicates with
everything around it it has a Global
Positioning System GPS so it knows where
it is and it has wireless communication
and transponder so it can send out
signals about where it is how fast its
wheels are turning the steering inputs
and other cars can read those signals
and do something smart with it
you can also communicate with locations
along the roadway autonomous vehicles
are vehicles that literally drive
themselves driverless cars I'll give you
an update on the state of this
technology then help you understand why
is it going to prove to be I think even
more important than propulsion
technology this is a vehicle that we
created in 2008 at General Motors called
boss a ghost is driving the car but
actually the car is driving itself
this grew out of a a competition let me
just go back and show it to you a little
more time this grew out of a competition
that took place in the United States
which required a car be designed that
60 miles in a city setting in less than
six hours without a person in the car
and no remote control we teamed with the
University in Pittsburgh called Carnegie
Mellon University Stanford University
which is another university here in the
United States teamed with Volkswagen
more importantly 85 teams enter this
competition
eighty five teams thought they could do
that thirty five built cars like what we
built 11 made it to the race finals her
half of the win the first place prize
was two million dollars General Motors
was going out of business so we needed
the money
but actually it was an amazing race and
what happened next is Google hired 12 of
the engineers from those 35 teams that
were at the race they didn't hire just
from the winning teams they hired from
some of the teams that didn't even make
it through the qualifiers because
they're looking for creative big idea
people over the next 12 months Google
then built 9th iota Priuses and they
figured out in California the law said
you needed to have somebody in the
driver's seat of a car but it didn't say
that person had to touch the steering
wheel the brake or the accelerator so
they took these cars on public roads
with an engineer sitting in the driver
seat and a technician sitting in the
passenger seat and they began to
accumulate public road experience now
obviously if something came up they had
a big panic button to turn the control
back to the engineer one of the jobs I
have now since leaving General Motors is
as a senior advisor to Google so I'm
working with this team on this
technology they're now up to 200
thousand miles on public roads with
these vehicles each month I travel to
Google and the first thing I do is write
in these cars on public roads each month
I'm going farther and farther between
when I have to hit the panic button it's
happening and it's real and it's
exciting
now if you watch this you begin to get
the sense of where might connect it in
all the time those vehicles tables you
can do whatever you want when you're in
the car because driving becomes the
distraction and you can manage traffic
is very innovative ways now you know I
kind of make make fun of that but but
the reality is all of this is within our
grasp and you might say when I can't
tell you that exactly because its
proprietary it's less than five years
for some applications and this is less
costly to do than a lot of these
alternative propulsion systems but what
does that have to do with energy first
of all you get more value for your time
in the vehicle in the United States and
I suspect this is similar in Europe
people spend about 60 minutes a day
behind the wheel that behavior behind
the wheel today are people talking on
their cell phone and eating and getting
distracted so what's the consumer
telling us driving is the distraction
why would you possibly send a text
message while you're driving unless you
thought that text message was more
important than driving safely so as a
researcher I concluded back around the
year 2000 2001 that we needed to have
cars that could drive themselves in fact
that one hour a day is worth quite a bit
of money to people on the order of half
the price of the car in a year so this
is a big deal for consumers more
importantly a car that can drive itself
as a car that won't crash and I'm sure
many of you and your travels have been
to some very busy subway stations I used
to go to the one and the Tokyo and just
sit there an amazement and watch people
get off trains that crisscross and one
thing I notice is they weren't running
into each other the people somehow knew
how to bob and weave not even looking in
your eyes but you knew how to avoid each
other so the algorithms exist there's no
reason to accept car crashes in my mind
anymore
and if we have cars that don't crash
really
the fatalities and the injuries but we
can make our cars lighter and this is
where energy gets interesting lighter
vehicles enhance efficiency and enable
better use of batteries whether they're
plug-in or fuel itself so the system
we're talking about is to change the one
fundamental thing we seem to always
accept about our cars is that they're
going to crash and if we can change that
with technology it can be
transformational
now we put one more thing into this idea
called the mobility internet you know
all of us are familiar with the
information internet it moves massive
amounts of data around and somehow when
you send me a text or an email it gets
to my box remarkable how fast it gets to
my box what we want to do now is to take
that same concept and enhance how people
on goods move around and interact so
think about managing our movement the
way the internet manages information
movement this will do for vehicles what
the internet did for computers it's
going to manage people goods vehicles
and infrastructure coordinate things at
millimeters and milliseconds as well as
mega meters and hours optimize traffic
flow and Road space and all of these
things and create some exciting
opportunities and this then sets up a
true design transformation for the car
back to this DNA electric and connected
that's and you put these two things
together will enable us to rethink
everything that we've assumed about the
car rather than the combustion engine
being in the front of the car
we'll have motors at the wheels rather
than steering mechanically or
hydraulically and braking that way we'll
do it by wire like with airplanes these
cars will have on the order of one tenth
as many parts in their designs and
they'll have new proportions and far
less mass so this boss of mine Rick
Wagner when I became head of R&D
he asked me an important question he
said Larry given what you know about
automotive tech now
today that we didn't know 120 years ago
and given the issues that we face with
the automobiles what would you do
differently
this is one of the big questions that
that's why he was our CEO you know I
asked my wife a question like that the
other night I said you know if anything
ever happens to me do you think you're
going to get remarried and she said I
couldn't get remarried you know you know
I just miss you too much I said well
you'd still be young she said I'll think
about it so then I said well if you do
get remarried will you let this guy have
my car I have this Cadillac XLR
convertible she said no that's that sure
that's your favorite thing she said I
said it'd be in the garage I'd be gone I
just make sense she says I'll think
about it
and then I said what about my golf clubs
and she goes oh no he's left-handed its
Rick Rick asked me a question like that
this is what we came up with first of
all they call it autonomy for freedom we
put the motors in the wheels we put the
energy storage whether it was battery or
fuel cell in the chassis so this is
almost like a skateboard and we said
let's dock the body on this like you
dock a laptop station amount of dock a
laptop computer on a docking station all
of the controls were by wire and it
began to set up a whole new design
architecture and you can begin to get
this appreciation of this skateboard and
how much fun that might imply at the
same time we were doing this a company
called Segway came out with a two-wheel
vehicle wheel motors balance machine and
we are kind of intrigued by that and
said you know Einstein said the best
design is the simplest one that works is
that what we really need to get to so we
married that thinking up with one of the
biggest mega trends that were
experiencing on our life which is
urbanization 2007 more than half the
people in the world began living in
cities and we came up with this notion
of reinventing personal mobility now if
you read the book and did all your
homework you'll know what we're taught
talking about its the electrification
combined with connected and autonomous
gives us that new DNA for the automobile
an urbanization sets up the opportunity
for the energy internet that's the
internet or the smart grid that's
managing the flow of these beats use
intelligently and the mobility internet
and you put all that together and that's
how we can reinvent the mobility that we
experience and that's what's documented
in that book but I think the story is
told better than in the book and it's
with this video one of the last
assignments I had at General Motors was
to think through the technology story
for the Shanghai World Expo GM and its
partner Shanghai automotive had the
exclusive rights to the pavilion on
mobility at the expo so we created this
concept called env electrically
networked vehicles or env for short the
designers really enjoy doing this
because they always felt that the auto
industry was about fashion so this was
actually something that has a lot of
interesting technology in it it drives
itself it doesn't run into other things
but it's also something that the
designers saws is what you would wear
rather than what you were drive to get
the auto industry back to its fashion
roots it's to passenger it weighs less
than a thousand pounds it has a small
battery three to four kilowatt hours
compared to the Nissan Leaf at 24
kilowatt hour battery the communication
system allows you to prioritize
emergency vehicles and begin to think
about traffic flow in new and innovative
ways this is just another representation
oh sorry
oh yes it could yeah and you can give
notification but the ability the ability
of these do not crash is key using the
communication technology and then you
can also think about innovative parking
schemes if we get to that next point you
can see the cloud in terms of the
connectivity you can begin to think
about inductive charging differently
again because it's such a small battery
a couple of generations more of
development on the battery the likely
mean you can remove that battery by hand
as we get the energy density up take it
into your apartment and recharge it like
you do the battery for your cell phone
you can provide mobility for people who
are less capable of driving in this case
the animated story involve a blind
individual you can come up with some
interesting parking concepts this one
maybe you don't want to do this if you
have a cup of coffee but this is sort of
the creativity of the Chinese that came
through as we put this together and then
finally it allows you to think about the
whole way in which your machine
interfaces with your home again it's
something you wear it's clean and quiet
and it's something you park in your
closet rather than your garage you know
I'm not telling you that this will be
exactly how the world plays out what I
am saying is that there's a very
exciting future and let me share a
couple metrics because measurement is
very very important here the first one
is a 15-time x improvement in energy
efficiency where did I get that I gave
you the calculation on the 1% of the
BTUs this will weigh one-fifth what a
car weighs so that's 5x electric drive
is three times as efficient as than buzz
that's three ups you put them together
it gives you a chance of a 15 next
improvement in energy that's still
wasting 85% of the energy but it's a lot
better than what we're going today so
it's all about designing with purpose in
mind the next metric is 10 X 1/10 as
many parts on the vehicle so these are
going to be very inexpensive things to
build compared to automobiles then that
is metric is 5x you can park five of
them in the space required a perfect car
here in Manhattan estimates are as high
as 25% of the miles driven are people
looking for a place to park the car
imagine that
and in Manhattan because that is such a
serious burden only 30% of the people
own a car so parking oftentimes is what
constrains the throughput of a city
the second 5x is cost per mile total
cost so not only is a vehicle one-fifth
as heavy and has 1/10 the number of
parts but because it doesn't crash and
it can be recovered with your GPS system
it's stolen your insurance costs are
dramatically lower and your energy costs
in your parking costs and your toll
costs so for people who today don't have
access to automobiles this lower cost
coupled with the driving capability of
the vehicle opens up that freedom that
many more people I think the most
important metric though is 0 X and
that's how many fatalities we would have
because we're going to take the crash
out of the system as important we're
going to take a lot of the mass out of
the system and we'll take a lot of a
deceleration from very high speeds out
of the system so what we're talking
about then is what you might
that hold it cause it didn't even sound
right so what about these girls
another excellent question I'll talk
about the challenge of implementing this
and that's right at the heart of that
challenge we think the key is to prove
prove these first in a controlled
environment but to be honest with you
the conventional cars can be equipped
with sensors and transponders at
relatively low cost to interact with
these now you may say you need a special
need a special roadway I think what's
very interesting in Europe's leading the
way on that a lot of cities are
restricting automobile travel in their
downtown areas because automobiles are
just not compatible with that kind of a
setting so we can begin to try these out
in situations where they don't mingle
with other cars but really all you need
to do is add a transponder to the
existing cars which will probably cost
less than $100 and it can send out a
signal I'm a car and I'm here and it can
share its data on how fast it's moving
and where it's going and so it's right
at the heart of the issue of
implementation but I think it is
something that if we can try it out we
can prove it out and get people's
attention so you put these three
internets together the information
internet the energy internet and
mobility internet and you get
transformational change in terms of how
we live our lives now I said at the
beginning I think the only thing that's
going to bring about large-scale changes
the market so can we give consumers
something better we've modeled let me go
back here a second
we've modeled this type of vehicle in a
community where not only are they
driverless and not crash not only are
they purposefully designed not only are
their paths coordinated precisely with
the mobility internet but their shared
they're not privately owned and very
very interesting results that suggest
that communities can have the same
amount of freedom as they have with
privately owned automobiles with about
one-fifth to one-tenth the number of
automobiles that dramatically lower cost
so that's what we're giving the
consumers the same level of freedom to
move around and interact significantly
lower cost and what we give society are
solutions to roadway crashes energy
consumption co2 inequality of access so
we think that that sets up for a pretty
exciting future I'm about to wrap up
here in a second so how do you get to
this how do you actually make it happen
first it had to get common understanding
and I know that's hard to do and that's
why I do what I do my second career dr.
Jim was to try to accelerate the
implementation of what I think is
possible and the only way we common
understanding of forms like this to get
the message out and until people have a
common understanding of what's possible
it's very difficult to get collective
will but to bring this about we're going
to need to have people focusing on it
together around the word and not around
the word or and in the United States in
particular we've had this never-ending
debate is a biofuels or electric
vehicles is a diesel or gasoline is it
fuel cells and hydrogen or plug-in
electric batteries in electricity it's
all of them and we need to do that in a
system of systems approach there's a
wide range of consumer needs light loads
too heavy loads city driving the highway
so one thing won't satisfy all of those
needs and you need to get to that magic
point I think this might be one of the
most important messages I leave with you
we shouldn't be fixating on the year
2050 we should be fixating on that
market tipping point what are the
necessary conditions to reach a point
where the value or the alternative
exceeds the price that people have to
pay for it and that price exceeds its
cost this is an amazing moment in market
economies people want it and companies
can make money supplying it and when we
get there with this whole suite of
technologies batteries and fuel cells
and biofuels and autonomous vehicles and
connected vehicles I think this is going
to tip and when it tips it'll tip fast
and tip nonlinearly you need to
recognize that the auto industry is as
much about fashion and fun as it is
about utility and the key to this as
engineers really is learning so you have
an idea and this gets back to your your
second question you need to prove it out
and demonstrate it that's what I'm
trying to do here at the earth Institute
is find a place to take this thinking
and try it for real and we have some
good candidates surfacing and we're
trying to get companies to participate
in this in the form of new business
models GM Volvo Daimler Erickson Verizon
IBM Cisco those kinds of companies truly
could come together in a new way and
perhaps bring this change about then you
need to do the generation one which
hopefully is good enough to get you to
generation two and three and then the
thing will tip then it'll scale and then
I will transform so that's what that's
really a thought process behind how to
make it happen the important point here
is that the whole is more than the sum
of the parts think about all of this
together don't get into that trap that
jeez I have to make some big decision to
mitigate the risk in my firm because of
all these batteries out there my god
Carla's going said he's going to put
through it and 50,000 units of capacity
in place to build batteries that's a big
number but keep in mind there's 70
million
and trucks being built worldwide this
thing's not going to run away from a
utility company or an energy company do
you need to understand that yes you need
to participate in the proactively yes
because you want to learn about it you
don't want to be caught not having the
knowledge necessary to play but when you
put all this together it really does
give us a chance to have greater freedom
sustainable mobility and growth and
prosperity now I want to leave you with
just two more thoughts the first is the
simple fact that we're creating electric
vehicles are making our combustion
vehicles better a different example in
the Ottawa industry is aluminum as a
material other than steel for an
automotive body has brought a lot of
value to the auto industry not because
of the aluminum on cars it's because
what it did to steel on cars half of the
steel alloys and automotive bodies today
didn't exist 10 years ago where did all
the innovation and steel come from the
threat of aluminum so the fact that
we're innovating with the Lumina
magnesium is having a benefit already
the fact that we have electric vehicles
being developed is having a benefit on
combustion engines two years ago in the
United States you could buy just two
cars that could get over 40 miles per
gallon on the highway with all the
hybrid now you can buy nine the auto
industry is responding to the threat of
the electric vehicle by making their
core technology better in fact plentiful
natural gas is not going to make coal
and renewables go away
call the renewables who respond the
plentiful natural gas in a very
proactive way to stay in the game so
it's not about picking winners
technology development is a very
competitive very dynamic process and you
need to be smart enough about what's
going on on all of these fronts and
again not get sucked into the belief
that you should bet on one thing it's
amazing how many people are out there
trying to pick the winner when in fact
all of these things will keep improving
the second point that I want to make is
we don't have to
get to scale to have an impact on some
of these big geopolitical issues a
proven option so take this concept I
showed you and do it in one place maybe
at the scale of 10,000 vehicles and show
that it's possible could change zhu zhu
political dynamics if i was king for a
day i would show opec that there is a
viable and scalable option to importing
oil into the united states ten thousand
electric or fuel cell vehicles in one
community using natural gas and biomass
as a source of hydrogen electricity I
think if we committed with that kind of
systems focus we would show a community
that's very happy with their
transportation system it's scalable and
then you sit down and you say do you
wanna talk and that's really what has to
happen here you don't have to get to
millions of millions and millions of
these in order to ultimately realize the
change you just have to show the world
that you can now the third thought I
want to leave you with is that there are
an awful lot of industries out there
that have been disrupted already so we
may be sitting here say my gosh the auto
industry has so much inertia and it is
so codependent with gasoline that will
never get out of the trap I'm sure
people in the photography media
entertainment Commuter telecom
television and pharmaceutical industries
felt similarly just in the last month
here in the United States an icon
company called Kodak is on the verge of
going bankrupt who would have ever
imagined that could happen incumbents do
not do well when industries disrupt so
if you're sitting here saying I'm a big
company I've been around a long time all
this stuff is going on no need to worry
about it a lot of people lost a lot of
value when that played out here I would
contend that transportation and energy
sectors are as right for disruption as
these industries were and that even
though there's a lot of installed base
to mitigate
that risk so again I'm trying to tell
you the disruption is right but I just
don't think it's gonna explode on us the
way some of these industries have been
caught but but it's going to happen I
really do not because of the politics of
climate change not because of the
national security associated with oil
because we can simply give consumers a
better answer a better option and give
companies a chance to make money off of
it so let me summarize that the
convergence of transportation energy
communications and then protect
information technology is going to be
transformational if the big companies
don't do it I can guarantee you
entrepreneurs will do it if the United
States or Western Europe doesn't do it I
can guarantee ax India or China or the
ASEAN nations will do it it will enhance
our lives and it's going to create a lot
of business growth and a lot of
shareholder value these industries as I
mentioned are very ripe for disruption
and either you're going to get in front
of that and be a player in it or you're
going to be putting your enterprise at
risk so let me stop there I think we
have some time for for Q&A and I
certainly appreciate your attention